it's day one of craft week and it's time
for another edition of
cookbook club and making dumplings oh
that is definitely not only a craft it's
an art
it's actually been on my bucket list for
my entire life
and i'm gonna get to learn how to make
them from none
other than wilson tang he is the owner
of
namwa tea parlor the first ever
iconic dim sun restaurant that's been
feeding chinatown new york
for a hundred years it's wilson
dumplings are and now my daughter her
favorite thing is pork dumpling oh
perfect we're going to be making some
shrimp and pork dumplings let's get
started let's do it okay
so what we have here already is the
ground pork
shrimp and mushroom mix mixture already
in the bowl
so shiitakes typically come like this um
dried
um how you activate this is just put it
in some water
and it'll it'll come into like it'll
kind of bloom like a flower
yeah so from left to right we have
sesame oil and we can just pop this
in uh as we go yeah we have some
white pepper next thing is is just a
chicken bouillon a chicken powder
that's what you have and that's in like
every one of the dumpling recipes
yeah use this sparingly just a little
bit uh we like using it in
a dumpling mixture just because it gives
a little punch and flavor no it's
it's delicious i get it so i can pour
this over yeah yeah you throw all that
in
um the next thing is a little bit of
sugar
sugar interesting uh
salt and uh finally just a little bit of
corn starch
which will help bind the the mixture
together
cornstarch is king so after you got all
the dry ingredients and the oil
sesame oil in here you kind of just mix
this up okay
um i think we're ready to wrap oh and
they're kept under a wet towel yes
which it says in the book yes so the wet
towel really um
keeps it from drying it out keeping them
yeah you're ahead of the game
well i did i when i say that i'm a
cookbook club collector i really truly
read them like novel that's awesome well
i i think you'll enjoy
our cookbook because it's not only just
recipes of the restaurant
there's the tea purveyor and the history
and like
how that might be too much okay what's a
good
rule switch to this okay like a teaspoon
yeah like just put
i think it said one and a half teaspoons
yeah so you just put some like right
smack in the middle okay and here's
here's the hard part right
like here's some water you dip the water
and um okay so you want the water to be
like
the glue on the rim so you circle the
edge
right and then um what you do first
is you press the middle
make sure that's really down pat and
then you just you just fold over
and then fold over again and then you
just squeeze
now you have something that looks like
that oh that
okay um i mean
hey that's pretty good yeah pretty good
yeah um i i know that you have
such an extraordinary story
yeah i mean like i was a typical you
know chinatown kid
uh a son of immigrants um you know
you know as as for immigrants from my
parents you know like being in the
restaurant industry was
was their only choice because of um just
language
and being new to the country so for me
like going to college getting a like a
white collar job was super important
for them um and i ended up doing that
you know i graduated from college
and had a job at morgan stanley and um
you know
then 9 11 happened and that really kind
of
changed my way of looking at at life um
you were in the tower yeah yeah so i'm
i'm like
what they say a 911 survivor i mean i've
heard you speak like on the vice
interview
that i watched of yours i mean you were
in the tower you were asked to walk down
the stairs
wow you did your homework huh and yeah
and
somewhere in the teens they said it's
okay you can go back up yeah i decided
not to
where i was i would have needed to walk
up back to 44 to cut the express
elevator up so i
it's actually laziness that got me out
of the building and once i got out of
the building i'm like this is not
good and that's when i decided to and
you walked back to chinatown yes where
my dad was working
and the second plane hit the tower yeah
and so i'm lucky to be alive today
and you took over your uncle's
restaurant turned it into an empire with
multiple restaurants it's been a great
ride
um you know i've been doing this for
over 10 years and i think the cookbook
really
kind of hones everything together you
know the cookbook is not only about
the stories and recipes of the
restaurant it's it's about the the mom
and pops and all these
characters uh in my community but lastly
it's also about like a legacy piece for
myself
so uh it was definitely multifaceted and
and not only are we doing fun stuff
making dumplings but um
it's it's definitely a book for
chinatown um all right
okay um after you've made you know a
bunch like this right you would
essentially have a steamer set up like
this i have one of these okay
so very little water on the bottom and
you got the setup and
when you steam it anywhere between eight
to ten minutes eight to ten minutes
will be good you can eat it just like
this or you can just kind of
put it into some oil and according to
the book it's one minute per side
right and again remind the uh the thing
you have to remember is this is already
cooked through
so what you're really trying to do is
just get some color
and texture
so how's yours look so far looking okay
very good yeah
okay like it's happening it's on
all right oh my gosh
that's awesome that looks that's great
yeah i feel like tom hanks is
okay here we go ready one two three my
first
dumpling ever
[Applause]
okay wilson so for cookbook club we
brought each other cookbooks to share
oh yes yes yes i have mine i have mine
too this is mine
okay what's yours so this is called
serving new york
made by an organization called roar but
the acronym stands for relief
opportunities for all restaurants a lot
of new york city chefs
have donated a recipe into this book
and all the proceeds go back to the
organization to help
with um the restaurant workers right
restaurant recovery
just to hold in industry as a whole it's
going to be a
a tough road ahead so this is what i
am gifting to you and recommending for
people to buy
and because the proceeds go to a good
cause well i'm very excited to add it to
my collection and for you
i have inside chef's fridges um this is
the european
edition it is the coolest cookbook so
when a chef comes on they show you what
they have in their fridge
and how to cook with it and it is the
most
incredible collection um
of extraordinary chefs that's so cool to
like take a peek into a chef's
like fridge yeah it's like going into
their closet or something i know
and exactly it's like going into a
designer's closet
and then they teach you how to put
together a fabulous recipe from it
amazing so this is my cookbook for you
thank you
thank you so much wilson thank you this
is
the biggest treat cheers dumpling cheers
thank you wilson thanks for having me
go to the drewberrymarshow.com for the
full recipe and the cookbooks
[Music]
you